PROFESSOR: So here it
is, connections formula,
connection.
So we'll take a
situation as follows.
Here is the point of x equals a.
I'll put just a here.
Here is the x-axis.
And I will imagine that I
have a linear potential.
So we have a linear
potential here.
Why do we imagine
a linear potential?
It's because the thing we
would really kind of want
to think about is what is called
the turning point, energy,
and a potential.
There's a turning point.
But it's clear that near
enough to the turning point,
this is linear.
And the problem for
the WKB approximation
fails, as we discussed, is
precisely in this region.
Now, I will make one
claim that this is really
what's going to connect here.
These two asymptotic expansions
that we've found here
are in fact WKB approximations
of our calculations.
So our whole procedure
here is going
to be assuming that we have
a linear potential here,
and I will take the linear
potential seriously.
So I will imagine it
even goes forever.
And what we're going
to do is find a way
from the turning point.
So the energy is
going to be here.
Here is v of x.
x v of x, the energy.
And then we have this region,
which is a WKB region.
And we have this region over
here that is also WKB region.
And the region in the
middle is not a WKB region.
It's a region where
all solutions fail,
WKB solutions fail.
They're not valid
in this region.
So let's assume, we have here,
therefore, a potential that
is linear, and, therefore
v of x minus the energy
is going to be a
number times x minus a,
where g is a positive constant.
It has some units.
v minus e is a linear function
that vanishes at x equals a.
So this is a nice
description of the situation.
And then you could
write a WKB solution.
So what is your WKB solution?
Let's write the WKB solution,
psi WKB on the right,
and then we'll write a WKB
solution on the left, the right
and left.
So here is what we.
Typical WKB solution
on the right.
That is a forbidden region.
Square root of kappa
of x, you would
have a decrease in
exponential, e to the minus a
to x kappa of x
prime, d x prime.
And then you have b over square
root of kappa of x, e to the a
to x kappa of x prime, dx prime.
So this is what you've
been told is supposed
to be your WKB approximation.
Decay in exponential,
a pre-factor,
growing exponential,
a pre-factor.
And kappa of x is something that
you know from this potential.
So this you would write for
any potential on the right
or on the left as well.
And here, your kappa of x
squared is 2m over h squared,
v of x minus e.
That's the definition
of kappa squared.
You're in the region
where v is greater than e,
and therefore, this is equal to
2m g over h squared x minus a.
So our next step is
a little calculation.
We should simplify all
these quantities here.
We should evaluate them,
because we have a kappa.
You have a linear function.
We can do the integrals.
We can put what kappa is.
So everything can be done here.
So if we do it, what do we get?
So evaluate.
We get the following.
Now, I will introduce some
notation to write this.
So first, I'll write
it, psi write of x WKB
equals 1 over
square root of eta.
That's a symbol I haven't
defined yet, u to the 1/4,
e to the minus 2/3,
u to the 3/2 plus b
square root of eta 1 over
u to the 1/4, e to the 2/3,
u to the 3/2.
OK, that's what you get.
You'll recognize
the a and the b's.
And here is what we need to
introduce a couple of variables
to make sure we know
what every symbol is.
And here, they are.
u is eta x minus a.
And eta is 2m g over
h squared to the 1/3.
Just roughly k squared
is proportional to u.
So k is proportional
to u to the 1/2.
And therefore, square root of
k gives you the u to the 1/4.
The integrals also
work that way.
And you see already
here, things that
look like the array function.
And that will become
even clearer soon.
So this is our solution for the
WKB expression on the right,
but let's do also the WKB
expression on the left.
The WKB expression
on the left would
be another wave of this
kind, but with cosines
or with exponentials
that we've done before.
So what did it
used to look like?
It used to look like
k of x and integrals
of plus minus i integrals
of k of x prime dx prime.
That was the way the WKB
solution looked like.
I'm now trying to write this
expression for the WKB solution
on the right.
Now, I want to make a
remark that even though I'm
using the linear
potential, in general,
if your potential,
even eventually
becomes something different
in this region, I'm good.
So I'm moving away
from the bad point
sufficiently so that the
WKB approximation is good.
But I don't want to
move away so much, so
that the potential fails
dramatically to be linear.
I have to straddle
limited region in fact.
I don't want to go too far.
So these were your
solutions before in a region
where you're in the
classically allowed region.
Now, this form of the solutions
will not be practical for us.
So I will write them, instead
with sines and cosines.
It will be better
for us to write it
with sines and cosines.
So let me write it
Psi left now WKB of u or x.
Sorry.
It's going to be c over
square root of k of x,
and I will write the cosine
of integral from x to a.
You see, I'm on the left.
So it's natural to write
integral from x to a.
On the other hand, on the right
was natural to write integrals
from a to x.
And that's what we did,
cosine from x to a.
We'll have here k of x
prime vx prime plus d
over square root of k of x
sine of x to a k of x prime dx
prime.
And you could say
look, that's good.
You just traded the exponentials
for sines and cosines,
and that's fine.
Still, for what we're
going to do later,
it's convenient to write
our WKB approximations still
in a little different way.
I can add a phase here
and a phase there.
And that still is the
most general solution,
because they're both
sines and cosines.
And unless I would put a
phase that differs pi over 2,
and one becomes equal
to the other, no.
I'm going to shift
both by pi over 4,
and therefore, these are
still different functions,
and it's convenient to do that.
So this is our onset
for the WKB solution.
We have to do the
same thing with it
here in which we expand and
evaluate in terms of and eta
in this quantity.
So what do we get?
We get c over square root of
eta u to the 1/4 cosine 2/3 u
to the 3/2 minus pi over 4 plus
d over square root of eta u
to the 1/4 sine of 2/3 u
to the 3/2 minus pi over 4.
So this is our
psi left WKB of x.
OK.
We're in good shape.
I'm going to raise this up.
And now you could say, all
right, you've done the WKB.
But on the other hand, how
about the exact solution?
What is the exact
solution to this problem?
You've written the
WKB approximation
for the linear potential,
the WKB approximation
for the linear potential.
Now, what is the exact
solution for the problem?
Well, your Schrodinger
equation is
minus h squared over
2n psi double dot
of x plus of x minus the
energy on psi is equal to 0.
Well, we've written this
already a couple of times.
So this is minus h
squared over 2m psi
double dot plus g x
minus a psi equals 0.
That is our v minus e.
And in terms of the u variable,
the differential equation,
of course, becomes the second
psi, the u squared equal u psi.
That's why the area
function is relevant here.
We get back to that equation.
That is the equation for
the exact linear potential,
and those would be
the exact solutions.
So our exact solutions are psi
being some linear combination
of the array function and
the other array function.
And now let's do one case first
before we get into something
that is more complicated.
Let's take psi to
be the solution
to be the array
function ai of u.
That's your solution now.
If that is your
solution, you would
have this behavior,
the behavior we've
noted here for this solution.
And now you compare and
you look at what you got.
You say, all right,
I have a solution,
and I know how it
looks rigorously,
how it looks to the
right and to the left.
That's how it looks, and
this is the exact solution.
This is the WKB solution, and I
know how it looks to the right
and how it looks to the left.
And I see the correspondence.
We see this term in
yellow is a solution
that this a decaying
exponential,
and we see it here.
And we have the red
term, the oscillations.
And we see it also here.
So here is that
connection condition.
In fact, when you derive
this asymptotic expansions,
you did the true
connection condition,
because you connected a
single function from the left
and from the right.
Here it was to the right.
Here it was to the left.
And it's a connection formula
because it's the same function.
So here, we see that if
we wrote the WKB solution,
and we were aiming at
maybe this solution,
we would have that this term
goes, connects with this term.
And the coefficients
differ by 1/2.
That 1/2 has no
other explanation
than the asymptotic expansions.
There's the square root
of pi, these things,
and there's the two functions.
So if you put the 1/2 is
there in the exponential,
so you could put the 1/2
here, and 2a, if you wish.
So you realize that in
order to have a connection
2a would be equal to c.
The two coefficients here
are related in that way.
There's a number here
and a number here.
It happens to be 2a
and c in this case.
So 2a is equal to c.
So if we choose a equals
1, we would have c equal 2.
So here is a matching
condition therefore.
We have that a WKB
solution that has
the c factor with c equals 2, so
it would be 2 overs square root
of k of x in here
times cosine of this x
over a k of x prime, dx prime
minus pi over 4 is connected--
we'll see more on that--
with 1 over square
root of kappa of x,
this solution with a equals
to 1, what we have here,
e to the minus a over x
kappa of x prime dx prime.
So that is the first
connection condition.
We will discuss it further
in a couple of minutes,
but this is how
you connect things.
A single solution of the
differential equation
looks like this term and
like that term on the left
and on the right.
Here is your WKB solution.
This general solution
looks like this term,
and it then should
match to something
that looks like that if you
have the array function.
So in general, for
not linear potentials,
this is the term that
gives rise to that,
so we take that
this term in general
is matched to the top term
in the blackboard here.